um as if we need any
last disastrous revelations about the
trump administration
as it ends uh we found out now
that the trump administration through
its coronavirus stimulus
actually gave 850 thousand dollars
listen to this to anti-vaccine
groups while the trump administration
publicly claimed to be pushing
vaccination
the trump administration gave
anti-vaccine groups
cash i guess because they were affected
by the pandemic it's
absolutely and completely insane five
prominent anti-vaccine organizations
known
to spread misleading disinformation
about the virus and vaccines
received more than eight hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
from the paycheck protection program
of course making us ask why
are they giving money to groups that
oppose their stated agenda
the stated agenda of the trump
administration is
vaccines are good and people should get
them and yet they gave money
to groups saying all sorts of
dishonest and deceptive things about the
virus and about vaccines the groups are
the national vaccine information center
should be called the disinformation
center mercola health resources
the informed consent action network
the chil children's health defense
and the 10 penny integrative medical
center
okay these are groups that to different
degrees
are anti-vaccine and spread anti-vaccine
disinformation some of these groups have
facebook pages
that have been suspended temporarily or
permanently
because they spread disinformation some
of these groups aren't allowed
to buy facebook ads because they spread
disinformation
and for some reason the trump
administration
through its ppp program gave them money
who could have guessed that there would
be abuse
when a program ppp that was supposed to
have oversight just doesn't
oh right that's actually completely
predictable and one of the
stories of the trump administration to
think about in the future
will be trump placating and pandering to
many lunatic fringes
anti-vaxx is just one of them one of the
really important things to understand
and over the last four years i i've
yelled at anyone who will listen to me
about it
we've done interviews about
conspiratorial thinking we've done
interviews about how these
types of thinking develop and the
overlaps between people
prone to what we call bottomless
skepticism skepticism is good
bottomless skepticism that can never be
satisfied that anything is as some
others say
is not healthy and what we found out is
that
not only are many trump followers prone
to conspiratorial thinking
uh trump himself has placated and
pandered to many of these lunatic
fringes anti-vaxx
we saw that very early in uh even during
the transition period of donald trump
um and uh we've seen trump placate all
sorts of other
lunatic fringes including those who
thought that there were i mean listen
first of all
the the so-called virus skeptics who for
months said it's like the flu
that's a lunatic fringe um but also
people with really wacky ideas about
uh how elections work and what the law
is around
elections and and anyway we've covered a
lot of them over time
uh but um what one other thing i was
thinking of is
you know donald trump said he considers
himself a wartime president he says
coronavirus is a war he said it was
against the china virus
that's not what we call it but he
believes that he has been a wartime
president
if you give money to the anti-vaccine
group during war
isn't that treason i don't know
certainly something to think about and
uh i i hope
my hope is that if the joe biden
stimulus happens
um i hope that the monitoring and the
regulation and the oversight
actually happens and this money to
anti-vaxx groups would be just one of
many things
that hopefully would be prevented we're
going to have more
including the inauguration of joe biden
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pakman